welcome to this video playing Pavel from
Israel let's see jeongnam so probably I
am let's let's play something else
Quincy too hmm while d5 here slightly
uncommon but certainly not bad i mean
it's just like I don't really know that
move we which one's supposed to UM the
Queens gambit style of position oh it
sticking with the Queen yeah well maybe
there's a similar line without 93 and
class holds and but then then Queen f5
is normal if they're the other the other
line but this is slightly different ok
Ollie for right why not just just grab
the center I don't know i don't think
that Queenie five is really good in this
position the other line you can play
Queen at five because then you fall it's
not possible well now it is possible
under and just just strong probably
see you file
hmm yeah I don't know
yeah white is some somebody had the
development I'm ready to castle and um
but still when knight c6 maybe it's
still ok I don't know I have some
discoveries mighty fine your fun zone ok
I need to recant your first
yeah I interesting them is attacking on
g2 and only for some some serious matter
so maybe here if I've also was
interesting but Queen takes Knight takes
bishop takes 95 I don't know well Bishop
f3 doesn't look bad on e5 I go on night
f5 guys if I've is weak hmm if I go why
it's not if I if you can just take of
course nonsense and
okay maybe I need to try something else
I can play Bishop c5 actually he does
not really need to take my idea was take
stakes 95 long castles so that after
night takes you three I can I actually
took interesting
but Bishop before what about this move
am I not winning material here yeah this
should win something yeah I thought I
just II 5v5 he can take on sea to play
95 this doesn't really help
and cute move this night f5 I know it
takes takes Bishop takes a text my queen
I was thinking I'm ruining the rook but
of course I don't yeah so what I want
really much done on time it's okay okay
let's play somewhat quicker but this
isn't so great actually now that I think
of it he can play but should be seven
now yeah this is I think just blundering
a piece isn't it attacking a eight and
deform but Bishop d7 he could play and
he will get get it back I think on e4
unless I'm overlooking something really
dramatic I'm winning a piece and it
doesn't really have any decent move
maybe boo nah no not really I thought
maybe Bishop e7 Queen takes Knight c5
with the tempo and then 93 at least
having a check available but um yeah
well maybe under the circumstances may
be the best solution and down on 135 and
I'm really don't know for what move did
I spent so much time there you are very
often asking this to myself
hmm yeah come on you need to move
something I came this one okay well I
need to take the book everything else
doesn't make much sense yes but I've got
rooked you one right there's no nothing
serious happening
yeah Ben Bishop e2 and castles I think I
can i can get the King out of the middle
and then it really should be just just
an extra look for no particular
compensation Knight f3 maybe is this the
most precise move Bishop
our Quincy success also good Jim this is
the easiest getting the Queen out yeah
this was I think the most precise way to
play it
yeah it's just look ready and now he
needs to exchange or give give another
piece black resigned yeah it was this
was interesting I mean I probably
misplayed it somehow maybe five him i
don't i don't really know it's
complicated Bishop f3 didn't really have
didn't really convince him yeah this
looks fairly solid for black if you
think about that it's not not bad but
this is really a was I was fine I
thought that 95 was the move that he
intended to play and then my idea at
least was to Castle long so that this is
just bad i think the combination of g
file the bishop is a quite quite a
problem and with this is just giving
away material interestingly enough the
computer wants to play 96 yeah probably
because of the Bishop d7 movie happy
should be seven it's still still okay
for black I need to play knight c6 here
and I'm not sure that I would have done
that I probably I would ya 97's a very
strong thread so he needs to take and
then I'm protecting with the Queen again
yeah the way it was plata this is just
just winning winning the house okay
thanks for watching